let's hear from some people in the
audience if you'd like to chat with me
you can go to davidpakman.com
discord we use the discord for calls and
that is a great great thing
let's start today with felix from
maryland felix you're on the air what's
going on
i did uh
not too much are you i'm doing well
thank you
cool uh i wanted to ask you excuse me
i'm a little sick uh do you think that
this day we're in the middle of a
political realignment
well well tell me more political
realignment of what kind
you know i don't know i've so i've just
kind of like been watching politics from
like afar for a while and
i i feel like
um
i just feel like a lot has changed in
like that like since uh
i really started paying attention more
back in like 2008 when obama ran i feel
like a lot has changed mainly from like
the cultural war i felt like a lot of
like culture and social issues were
um
making people who are sort of apolitical
or
um not really uh you know super focused
on politics uh it would help them come
more to the left
um because a lot of people i felt like
were turned off because the right was
more like a family value social
conservative type of party yeah i feel
like that's changed a lot and you know
the right and the republicans are like
now like they've completely abandoned
especially with after trump they've
abandoned the whole like
um you know family judeo-christian
values aesthetic and stuff and now i i
just i weirdly see that the culture were
starting to like benefit them
well i
so let's see you're absolutely right
about some of these particulars that
you're noticing
um i don't think it's a realignment in
the sense of
republicans and democrats are switching
and what it means to be in one party
versus the other i don't think that
that's changing i think the realignment
that we're seeing
is that
it started under obama and it exploded
under trump and it's continuing now
republicans are no longer even
pretending to be about policy they are
as you pointed out they're about
cultural issues they're about owning the
libs they're about trying to win
elections by
deciding which ballots do and don't
count they're not really making
substantive and meaningful political
cases to their voters saying here are
the things we will do and here's why it
will help you they'll still vaguely say
the democrats are crushing us with debt
or they're crushing us with taxes or
whatever but that that's like that's not
that doesn't count as policy in my mind
you're not really
substantively proposing alternatives and
solutions other than we'll cut taxes and
we'll you know pay down the debt which
they don't ever do um
but i think that the realignment is that
they used to at least pretend to be
about policy they don't even pretend to
be about policy anymore
you know um yeah i i think that's true
to an extent
uh
i i i definitely feel like yeah they
used to pretend to be about policy and
like on the like cultural issues they
they used to be all about like upholding
you know family values and stuff like
that like i was saying yeah but
i feel like i feel like now
i i don't know i just feel like i've
seen like more a little bit more like
diversity in thinking of some people who
would like vote right wing and the fact
that like a lot of them seem to even
like support drug legalization a lot of
them have kind of like come to terms
with letting you know allowing uh
same-sex marriage and things like that
right and uh no that's a good point
curious
i'm curious like where where this is
going because even
like
in a few years from now like what
what are they uh what what are the
what's the party going to look like and
what is
their vote what are their uh base and
their voters going to look like if this
continues i feel like they could win
over
a lot of uh people on some of those
issues that
yeah i mean what you're pointing to is
that there were a bunch of people who
before trump were never politically
engaged or motivated at all and what
trump was able to do was find people who
never paid attention to politics and
basically say
here are your values and vote for me and
i'm a republican so trump did
to his credit bring in people who
believe themselves to be for example
against military interventions around
the world because trump claimed to be
against that but trump's not really
against that it was just a way that he
was able to criticize george w bush um
you're right that they don't seem to be
homophobic uh some of these folks at
least not outwardly so because donald
trump did not make that a big part of
his campaign i think you're absolutely
right but i think the bigger question is
do those people really stay engaged in
politics after trump is gone and we
don't know the answer to that yet they
may or they may bail
okay yeah well it's just been really
interesting it's just all the time i say
these days if i could like go back in
time and tell myself like this would be
the environment would look like 10 years
from now it
i would be shocked yes it would anyways
it would i appreciate it you have a good
day thank you have a good one all right
there we go there's a there there's
felix
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
and it's a sponsor i'm thrilled about
because i sleep on a helix mattress at
home and it's just the perfect mattress
one of the best things about helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do i need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type your sleeping position your
back pain issues you might have and they
will pair you with a mattress that will
be perfect for you i took the sleep quiz
the mattress they suggested was exactly
what i needed i often get too hot at
night the mattress keeps me cool it's
not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right and i've just been
getting way better sleep you only buy a
mattress every decade or so
don't get stuck with something that's
not perfect for you and all helix
mattresses come with a 10-year warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within a hundred days if you
don't love it but i think you will all
of my viewers will get up to 200 off
your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows for free when you go to
the link right underneath this video